migliaccio guarda fissa di castori per
oggi a grandissima richiesta torna la
storia pauroso questo è un altro
ascensore quindi l'ascensore dell'orrore
questo dovrebbe essere il più pauroso di
tutti come sempre gioco che mi piace
ormai sapete come funziona stato un mi
piace per scoprire che personaggio siete
questa volta mettetevi comodi perché poi
alla fine del video dovrete dirsi qual è
secondo voi il personaggio che ha fatto
più paura se tutti anche noi vi di
lavoro il personaggio che ti ho fatto
più paura chi vincerà secondo voi
vincerò io ho vincerà vitale promette
bene iniziando ok
eccoci qua io ho il mio outfit da taylor
moon a vi piacciono i migliori kimi è
invece è vitale già scappata davanti a
entrare nella storia vediamoci pratiche
minuti ovviamente se integrativi e tip
un tapis roulant
sì possiamo usare l'ascensore è che
succede qua
ora questo la musica andiamo wagner
freddi sì ma ci sono le camere si sono
chiuse le porte
ok si è aperta quella porta andiamo
eccolo che parlerò tra poco dovrebbe
prendere vita fare molto attenti quando
prende vita a scappare io continuo nome
non ci credo perso al primo piano ppb
cuore risalgono la gens aree anche se ho
perso i punti più tutti allontani dalla
sensore più punti fi
quindi tu rimani tempo
ma l'assenza orio rimani senza è uscito
qualcuno rimane fermo poi i pochi punti
ecco perché ci si sposta però ovviamente
se vieni preso ma comunque meno punti
sono gli alieni hanno preso sono
riusciti a eliminare fatti tutti bravi
ok sono rientrata che ha fermato e nu
preso lo beve un pelo cose desse vita a
muovermi ha detto ecco perché il razzo
anche dentro l'ascensore piace il mio
outfit con le mie orecchie o non mi
ricorda che eravamo già arrivati oggi
c'è uno yeti uno yeti lo vede così
piccolo rieti che cos'è ma qualcuno ha
il coraggio di che è successo si è preso
tutto qui
che cos'è un mostro e non lo so per me è
abbastanza torna dentro la noia non mi
ha preso per un pelo è bruttissimo come
si chiama voi lo conoscete news monolo
conosco c'è un buco
no grazie io non voglio buttarmi forse
meglio lo so penso che sia l'unica
opzione diamo
siamo pozzo non lo so che cos'è tutto
nero ma poi non vedo niente
noi facciamo ritornare su nell'ascensore
guarda ma no no no non mi aspetto la
luce non aiutano buddista da voi aver
sbagliato quel fatto quanti mandati
naruto quanti punti ha fatto tornare
[Musica]
fatemi tornare solo fatevi dare tu non
equa la via d'uscita dove devo andare
allora aiuto qui siamo tutti su e giù ci
sono riuscita sono caduto dentro un po
così
però siamo nell'ascensore di nuovi 1.300
punti
no no no e altre ne andrà
siamo in un altro mondo un portale
allora c'è qualcuno li arrivato qui poi
lo conoscete meglio nascondersi o no è
diventato tutto buio è già scappata
non rimango fermo fermo dietro un
ambiente non capisco dove tra l'altro si
è arrabbiato ma come faccio io scappare
ha detto proprio andando benissimo
questa volta 1500 punti prossimo piano
andiamo spaventa siamo tantissimi motivo
in una una prigione hai visto il cattivo
o no cos'erano
non lo so accendete la luce è sì quanti
punti stiamo facendo
dove non lo so non si vede tutto e qui è
una maschera tv dopo questo cattivo non
hanno mai visto
sembra cartoon cazzo da lontano ma non
lo è
che strano i suoi provvisto di prossimo
ci sarà il cattivo
possiamo forse qualcosa riguardo
minecraft è questo forse meglio non
avvicinare non so quanti punti si crea
dove dove stiamo male siamo tornati
successo forse forse siamo abbiamo fatto
tutti i piani dell'ascensore
non ci credo forse non ero vogliono
farci credere che stiamo infatti tornati
all'entrata ma in realtà è solo una
simulazione vinto
1 giu siamo stati fregati alla grande se
devo buttare attenti invece nella
simulazione tutti questi personaggi
hanno preso vita
abbiamo perno facciamo un'altra partita
e vediamo quanti altri livelli di sap
appare comunque per ora o 1.175 punti in
giù 1760 qualche dinosauro qualche
animale pericoloso perché si insabbia
erano degli animali viola li ho visti
noi non vedo niente
che cosa sta succedendo sì sì che faccio
più punti e vivo livello
vogliamo un po indovinare prima che
arrivi il cattivo qui c'è qualcuno euro
un robot si si si si io scappo stava
ciao stare qua dietro verminator cosa
sta succedendo rotta arrivando qui ma
questo nostro amichevole
non lo so ecco ha iniziato a muoversi io
sono nascosti una canzone del solito
fico
aiuto aiuto aiuto arrivando qua vicino
cento con questa pizza in mano
aspettando
crediamo che ciò è qualcos'altro si
grillo o il pezzo di pizza ma il toro e
ti affrontare i nemici prossimo livello
che cos'è il secondo tempo è visto un
labirinto horse è un fantasma proviamo a
convincerlo offrendogli la pizza vedere
la vita al vostro riuscirà a resistere 8
marzo non si posso credere voglio subito
che non mangio io qua quindi a dove
vivere
qualcuno è stato già eliminato nostro
dovrebbe essere qualcosa ti aiuta mostro
veniamo in pace di sto portato un pezzo
di pizza guarda sento questi sussurri
strabella perdermi questo labini torna
in ascensore a mangiarmi la vita che
sebbene questo sia questo
chi è il mostro e questo vorrà la pizza
prova ad angela è bello sopravvissuti
anche se non ho capito bene perché gli
ha offerto un pezzo di pizza sia per
quello di bossi contempo test ok
penso che ci ha mandati radioattivo è
quello no quello corto raggio attentato
attenta perché ha eliminato un paio di
giocatori già roma non fa molta paura
questo sono un po strano che è successo
non lo so tutto buio
ok sta tornando lasciamo aspetta sta
andando nella direzione sbagliata non si
fa a non andare questa volta tutti mi
prendono vita quindi io mi nascondo
questi sopra libereranno tutti cattivi
dalla dentro ma cosa si fa era in mezzo
de min accollarsi dove mi nascondo non
so dove nascondermi guarda che ti
prendono adesso sono animati io sono
passato la sua casa di legno
spero che non stancano qua stanno
cercando tutti forse siamo nascosti bene
e non ci credo se volete sopravvivere da
qui così cos'è questa è dove siamo
sottoterra
chi sarà il mostro ma secondo te un
lombrico né giglio lato è vero forse
qualche no no no siamo troppo
una talpa sta arrivando sì perché z
perché uno dei cattivi qua strada
arrivando dentro l'assenza stata
protetta tutti noi
non mi prenderei mai spero che non entri
qua dentro
no entrato per un pelo di sauro si
arriva al tiro per azione
a sentire meglio tornare troviamo
l'ascensore eccolo qua si è provato a
offrirgli la pizza al tiro non sono
meglio che ti allontani di robinho
diminutivo di faccio a prenderti rapida
e approcci sani belli mai prof
supermario
ok posto per mario ma ingrato supermoney
fra il cattivo allora uomo ma adoro
questa mappa e qualcuno quindi la gabbia
e sonic peraltro sonic e veloci e magari
è meglio che scappi proprio veloce non è
uscito dalla gabbia
tutto questo purtroppo poi ben sapendo
che si è fermato lì
come mai si è fermato abbiamo capito
anche fare l'ultimo piano siamo in una
scuola va al di là e compagni si
riconosco dove è tutto buio
aiuto aiuto solo nel bagno della scuola
ma non vedo più niente
dov'è che preso no quasi agli studi se
questo bar e mi avevi lasciato re
io mi sono nascosto a questo la scienza
dall'angolo che viene a quello che io
entrato wow state difficile baldi mito
con fabra primo livello a un pezzo di
pizza
roba da lui tutti quanti prego salve a
tutti come pezzo di pizza ma solo voi un
pezzo di pizza attento sbotta tv dove
sei nota e spiaccicato nonno allora io
ho fatto 5400 sempre
cinque punti e tulipano 60 tirava ho
vinto questo perché i temi soffrire ma
pizarro sono gentile un'offerta pizza
alla più paura secondo me è fatto file
nighter freddi del secondo tempo quello
non l'ho visto perché ero impegnato a
scappare abbiamo fatto più paura il
pagliaccio e secondo voi mai state più
paura scrivetecelo rapida siamo quattro
case vinse qui cliccare per vedere
inoltre altri video capi su quella che
preferite
buona visione ciao